[Applaudissements]
j'aime la tâche
alors oui mais révélateur que
sa soeur s'en lécher la fenêtre ouverte
aujourd'hui
on dirait marine le pen après le bac
soit
bonjour à tous bienvenue aux faibles
je n'ai rien tout non candela
faut répondre à mes questions à
commencer bat mathieu débauche d'efforts
padieu première question donne-moi trois
choses que l'on peut enfiler rapidement
à gaza
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un pull un pantalon et des gants valérie
oui on dit bon sang
ça allait quel célèbre émission
christophe dechavanne at-il animé au
maroc réponse
[Musique]
[Rires]
parce que c'est donc ça marche
ça marche à la wii mise à part noël
qu'est-ce qui peut être ma mère mes
implants oui
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
calme toi toi t il c'était un
chroniqueur de touche pas à mon poste
parti trop tôt bip petit ange
nicolas pernikoff
il irait donc gynéco rachid arhab maxime
g 10 jean pascal est le pauvre
sais même pas qui c'est c'est la bonne
réponse
et la paire d'as oui lequel de ses
anciens joueurs de foot existe vraiment
bouboule ou cocu hockey ont-ils indiqué
[Rires]
changer la première lettre du monde boy
pour en faire un autre beau
oui avec bakou ya évidemment il y avait
aussi oui nous ils fouillent mouiller et
donc attention mais n'ont pas mis
caminada smith avec avait été laissée à
billets
ont ricané de poisson qu'elle énerve les
automobilistes et qu elle excite
d'asnières de quoi je parle
les bouchons
ont dit qu'elle énerve les
automobilistes et qu'alexis daniel enfin
bien que
[Rires]
l'attention vrai ou faux chevaline
amadou et mariam sont ivoiriens
[Musique]
il s'en va les uns par contre ivoiriens
[Applaudissements]
je te connais c'est moi toi
et pousse pousse question que peut-on
trouver à la fois au bois de boulogne
dans un slip assure une pizza ta mère
d'élève élue il devient
mais pas pas d'où il vient ni
donc redonné en arabe cahoon a bien
le tour n'est pas fini je continue ouais
j'en fais un tour c'est
mathieu a donné moi à ou qui vous
caractérise le plus qui commence par la
lettre p prétentieux et non
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui peut-être de bus du maçon
ou manta de bus du maçon
oui quel est le nom du boulevard
parisien où se situe donna bien
[Rires]
c'était moi un prénom qui n'est pas
celui là des trente six enfants de
castanet
louis oui j'ai vu aussi patrick boivin
et plein d'autres choses
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est votre voix oui
pour toute la famille des colloques
mythique des colloques des goûts
chig régulièrement sur nos pare brise à
paris
le maire l'api le pays
calme toi je sais que je plais 10
revendre et elle ressemble un flan
pâtissier of a few
commandites ont rayonné rigoler dans la
non je ne sais pas mario l'eau
[Applaudissements]
ces cadeaux ça fait plaisir que moi je
suis là
haut niveau qui commence quelle est la
première chose dans laquelle je vais
pénétrer un avis il n'est pas autour de
cette fois
un cube
c'est payet larminat de leurs
regards vers l'aéroport aussi
ses portes à leurs questions vrai ou
faux dans la version 2022 je me
rapproche qui me plaît dit mme aubry si
on perd cela car hanouna on obtient
automatiquement je recule c'est pas
prévu
un immeuble avenue montaigne ou un
pied-à-terre à new york
[Applaudissements]
va les y répondait ni
et mes impôts
[Applaudissements]